ma proprio un lavoro della tutti ragazzi
e benvenute questo io sono vari j
ed oggi mi trovo che la cosa migliore è
sparita una persona questo gioco si
preannuncia veramente bello io da
italiano non posso che vomitare alla
vista di questa pizza ragazzi oggi siamo
su t cell simulator perché voi lo sapete
in fondo che siete iscritti al mio
canale perché io trovo giochi di qualità
voleva abbassata per aumentare la
grafica e pensare che quella di primera
la grafica al massimo ragazzi siamo nel
mio nuovo lavoro perché farei youtuber
non è assolutamente un lavoro quindi io
mi sono cercato un lavoro e oggi faccio
il raccoglie immondizia chiamiamola così
perfetto lavora in un ristorante che si
chiama che si chiama non lo so però il
posto nel insegna c'è un muffin
gigantesco a io devo portare il tutto
tutto quello che mi chiede la gente ok
un attimo che qua ci sono le cose da
dove c'è mai magnetica questa paletta
attira il cibo in modo mani e della
madonna
io devo sottostare le richieste della
gente ad esempio quell'uomo tutto solo
perché effettivamente in un ristorante
così scadente che ti pace vuoi guardare
per rimarcare la zia vuole un'arancia
riportiamo subito un'arancia eccola qua
tieni uomo solo ha posto affittato stava
mangiando una fetta di limone facciamo
finta di niente tanto siamo nel 1960
ragazzi ciechi ruby e cucina c'è proprio
in cucina perché allora questo video di
dobbiamo a cannavacciuolo che so che
apprezzerà la mia cucina vero c'è allora
signor canavacciolo la vede questo pezzo
di pizza che napoli in confronto se la
sogna una pizza così tutti i napoletani
che
questo sto scherzando è di ironia
scherzo come sice scherzi il napoletano
age scherzava age scherzi quella mai uno
staff it all fatto meglio è un attimo
non è solo un pezzo di pizza il suo
posto ma la vantura offre la casa penso
di limone non sono sicurissimo che così
sia un limone per ottenuto lo stesso non
era un limone perché tu hai un di monia
di monet eccolo perfetto e voi un altro
rimane averti vedere il video che ho
fatto con giulia penna con ancora bene
dove comunque ordinativi i piatti
sostanziosi tutti quanti ha canotta bene
la carota troviamo qui solo una fetta
però a ok a posto sia inizio metà pezzo
di pane a veloce valigia ma poi l'altra
metà va bene girato rapporto subito e
fresco questo è fresco di giornata
bene c'è qualcuno che desiderano muffin
si desiderava fino a si lavano grazie
eccolo ora non volevi e trovai e cazzi
tuoi
apri la boccuccia a per fai il bravo a
fino a tele fortunato tranquillo apriva
non è esattamente un pezzo di limone ma
secondo me puoi farcela zio poi facile
un uomo solo e la sua anguria alla
ragazza in questo locale accettiamo
tutte le tipologie di uomini quelli dei
quali non gay però emettono gas di
colore decente almeno quello
carl zeiss volete un pezzo di carota va
bene ma io non ho capito se carletto
dovrebbe essere questo sì è un pezzo di
carota 1 solo bene
spero che vi sassi che voi ci crediate o
meno questo gioco l'ho pagato anche 2
euro
fatemi uscire per lo meno male che ogni
volta che ci aiuta perché mi fa capire
che sono usciti
dal gioco credete che l'ho comprato la
bellezza di euro e 99 kitsch e sicurezza
2 perché esiste chi chelsea moletto 1
visto il successo incredibile hanno
fatto dice simulator 2 6 2 così bello
non oso pensare il primo quanto potesse
esser bello quello che ho comprato io
costa 2 euro questo costa 1 euro quindi
sai che ti dico
fanno lo steve stimento dai e niente
neanche stimi dagli errori qui della
serie proprio non comprare questa merda
ti prego e la madonna mezzo giga
c'è un giovane 2c capicolli prima di
girare il percorso della qualità del
suono del rutto del menu solo per
farvelo notare skyrim pesa 5 giga e
mezzo questo ne pesa 2 non è la metà ha
quasi skyrim e non è che sto dice skyrim
vedo l'ora di vedere perché cosa un peso
i miei soldi
quasi quasi lo metto il russo almeno
sciocco disfida conti conti patricia
continuità continua cosa che ho appena
comprato cosa continua gesù cristo
io vi giuro su quello che volete che non
pensavo potesse essere più brutto
dell'altro e germania invece è più
brutto nell'altro riesce a fare più
schifo di cui prima incredibile questa è
una a very nice
questo cos'è un coltello è una paletta
tipo un secchio se con dentro ma di meno
cosa vuoi nice place ho capito casolare
di cibo ma anche nei the schiappa di
stop da una signora che a prendere le
cose ora io questo è un gioco nel 2015
ci ho messo due anni per fare un
miglioramento di poponi prima che
chiamarlo miglioramento è veramente
troppo un complimento ma raniero
nell'altro riuscivo a prendere qualcosa
basta andare a fare in culo il cibo
prendi a pian piano piano piano no porca
vacca quanto difficile
vecchia piano piano
madonna è cazzo storia lesbica grafica
alta mi chiamerà mare che ha impostato
su aldo per vedere un basso gesù buon
dio come mai vedo tutta sta roba con la
grafica in alta che questo dovrebbe
rappresentarli per la ragazzina lezione
che se via la gente o quale problema
una donna [ __ ] sono riuscito a
incastrare un pezzo di anguria nel
tavolo che ha vari contendenti questi
che sono vicini che scaldarli si tiene
banco è buono ti prego maggio ca vacca
infame la persona rischio prenderci
vodka da toto baby ubriaca di più briani
tu non mi ubriaco io effettivamente non
augurano tutti i torti dopo quello che
sto vedendo ragazzi ditemi voi se non è
l'euro più ben speso di tutta la mia
vita ragazza non contento proprio felice
ci ho provato a fare un lavoro normale
medi con gli haters file altro oggi va
bene non sono in grado per farmi farlo
youtuber e non rompere i [ __ ]
quindi ragazzi spero che questo video vi
sia piaciuto cose il momento mi piace
spero che tutti gli italiani non si
siano offesi per aver visto una pizza
come quella di prima però ci hanno
provato dai diavoli del credito questi
poveri programmato la misura mente
piacenti altare con video dalla
descrizione si stiano ci vediamo al
prossimo visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]